je crois pas à la vaccination
obligatoire pour ce vaccin et après je
crois beaucoup plus au travail de
conviction par la transparence cal
l'obligation la vaccination sera rendue
obligatoire sans attendre
[Musique]
[Rires]
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois pas à la vaccination
obligatoire pour ce vaccin parce que
d'abord il faut être toujours très
honnêtes et transparents on ne sait pas
tout sur ce vaccin comme on ne sait pas
tout sur le virus et après je crois
beaucoup plus au travail de conviction
par la transparence cal l'obligation
nous mettons tous les moyens pour
vacciner vacciner vacciner sans répit
cent jours fériés le samedi et le
dimanche comme la semaine est ce que le
vaccin y sera obligatoire si oui quel
âge monstrueux c'est plutôt de ne pas le
rendre obligatoire mais c'est de
convaincre tout le monde que c'est par
le vaccin que nous pourrons nous en
sortir il faut qu' entre 70 et 80% de la
population qu'ils soient vaccinés ou
qu'ils aient les anticorps pour que le
virus s'arrête de circuler au sein du
pays la question s'était posée il ya
quelques mois d'une vaccination
obligatoire des soignants je constate
que par à la fois la conviction par
aussi sans doute l'exemple
cette vaccination ont beaucoup augmenté
elle est aujourd'hui autour de 75 % des
soignants qui sont vaccinées dans notre
pays donc je crois qu'il est plus
efficace de passer par la conviction est
aujourd'hui de ne pas rendre la
vaccination obligatoire la vaccination
se poursuit à marche forcée c'est
pourquoi nous avons décidé ce matin à
partir du 15 juin et bien 12 de
commencer à ouvrir la vaccination pour
les adolescents enfin les plus jeunes
[Musique]
[Rires]
tous les vaccins disponibles en france
nous protège solidement contre ce
variant delta nous devons aller vers la
vaccination de tous les français
car c'est le seul chemin vers le retour
à la vie normale dans un premier temps
pour les personnels soignants et non
soignants des hôpitaux des cliniques des
maisons de retraite des établissements
pour personnes en situation de handicap
pour tous les professionnels ou
bénévoles qui travaillent au contact des
personnes âgées ou fragiles y compris à
domicile
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire
sans attendre en fonction de l'évolution
de la situation nous devrons sans doute
nous poser la question de la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous les français mais
je fais le choix de la confiance et
j'appelle solennellement tous nos
concitoyens non vaccinés à aller se
faire vacciner dès aujourd'hui au plus
vite